we have to start with your relationship
with the president
of course you only lasted 11 days as the
white house communications director back
in 2017 what happened
well i mean i did work from for a year
prior to that and i was on the executive
transition team but
but i think you guys know what happened
it was a well-documented mistake i
i trusted a reporter who was a you know
family friend
the his dad had gone back with my dad uh
in the construction community on long
island
for 50 years and i said a off-color
remark
to him which he recorded unfortunately
and he ran to cnn and
i said to him hey if you do that you're
going to get me fired
and of course he did that and i got
fired so it was my fault
i don't blame anybody for that i was
right about steve bannon by the way but
i shouldn't have said it the way i said
it but that's life how should you have
said it do you think
well i think uh you know the truth be
told
uh when you did a clinical assessment an
objective assessment about steve bannon
he was a migallo maniacal egocentric
white nationalist and so a very
dangerous guy to have in the white house
and so
for me i think my singular greatest
accomplishment thus far
in american history was helping to get
him out of that white house
and he left uh shortly after my
departure
uh and i was able to expose a lot of the
things that he was doing not only to the
president but to the country
and so uh you see him here today uh he's
obviously under arrest we'll presume him
innocent uh because of the way the due
process works in the law but that
doesn't take away the fact
that of my opinion of him which i think
he's a very bad guy you spoke of the
president there did you ever like him as
a person
i got along with president trump i mean
he's not well suited to be
the president so you just have to just
separate the man from the office of the
presidency
and the colossal task of the presidency
and its responsibility
uh when we were in new york together uh
whether we were socializing or at a
yankee baseball game or a charity event
he is a you know gregarious uh
could be charming at times a wrong
contour of a guy
uh it's just unfortunately that skill
set that he has
wasn't transferable into the office of
the presidency
it got him the office i mean there's no
question about that he has great
communication skills
and he was able to tap into an anger
that the american electorate
has about the washington establishment
you wrote a book about that didn't you
back in 2018
trump the blue collar president um how
far does he still
appeal do you think to the blue collar
ahead of the 2020 election
well listen i think i think he still
appeals to them there's been a vacuum of
advocacy
for blue-collar people in the united
states for many decades
and so for whatever reason the
establishment of both sides has
neglected them
uh i think vice president biden is a
different sort of personality than
secretary clinton and he was a
a man from scranton connecticut i grew
up not too far from where my parents
were raised and so
uh he has that blue collar vibe about
him
uh i think what it will really come down
to is a culture war
ultimately the president was right he
could shoot people on fifth avenue and
there's a very large group of people
that are going to stay with him no
matter what so
when you see the liz pendants of
different things that he's done as
president or things that are coming out
that he did prior to the presidency you
know it's sort of colossal
it's sort of a meteor strike on him and
yet he's able to stay in there
primarily because we're in a great
culture war in the country
and there's a large group of white
americans that think that he is their uh
last great white hope
but is you know his connection with the
blue collar segment of american society
he is a multi-billionaire that is very
happy
to flaunt his wealth so what is it that
helps him connect with the
with that segment of society that you
illustrated there well i did write about
that in my book i was on
71 different campaign stops with him uh
for whatever reason the way he got
raised by his parents he was on a lot of
construction sites as a kid
uh and he he was able to tap into that
angst you know
i would say my dad who was a blue collar
uh
hourly worker uh but he had a good he
had a good wage we lived decidedly in
the middle class i would never dishonor
my dad's work ethic by
telling you that i grew up poor but that
very same job
today uh he couldn't have afforded his
family you know the real wages
are down 25 percent and so the president
figured out that there was a group of
people that were once economically
aspirational as blue-collar people
and they have now become economically
desperational and that happened in 35
short years and he was able to tap into
that now unfortunately the policies that
he's put in place
have not helped those people and his
mishandling of the pandemic has
exacerbated the problem
in most of those areas of the country so
there's great irony there as well
and again you just have to look
objectively at what he's done uh between
the failure
of the health care crisis the
dismantling of the economy we're in the
worst recession now since the great
depression the bellicosity of his
rhetoric
the weakening of our alliances in some
of the post-world war two
architecture if you will that has led to
such great peace and prosperity
uh he shouldn't really be president you
know we gotta we gotta send him to
mar-a-lago hopefully in the next 55 or
so days
what about the race protests that we
have seen over the last
few weeks what impact do you think that
will have coming up to the 3rd of
november
well i think it's a it's a two-sided
coin so i think
there's one side of the coin where the
president's preaching law and order
there's great irony to that because
this stuff is happening in trump's
america so his convention speech was uh
i'm here to save you from donald trump's
america my name is donald trump so
there's a great irony there but there's
a group of people that see him
as quote unquote law and order even
though there's been lots of malfeasance
in his life
uh and then on the flip side there is a
lot of racial anxiety in our country
there's been a strain in the country for
several hundred years
and it's been exacerbated now because we
have iphones and smartphones where we
can
record things that are happening that
look very very unfair
and look like high levels of social
injustice so
there's a two-sided coin if the
african-american community the latino
community turn
out in high volume similar to what they
did
with barack obama and they vote for joe
biden because he's got about 85
or so of that community he'll decidedly
win the race but there
is a again a struggle there's a class
war
going on in the society there's racial
tension going on in the society
and we've even politicized wearing masks
which i think is you know we've
disavowed levels
of scientific fact which i think is
nonsensical
uh all of that is in the soup here we'll
have to see what happens but i think the
vice president will win this
vice president biden will be the 46th
president what do you say to those who
say you're just being bitter because you
were fired by the president
well i mean they're entitled to that
opinion but just look at the record i
was with the president i got fired
for two years you can find tons of video
of me
advocating for the president and
advocating his policies
i love the president i obviously love
the country look at my life experience
here in the country
and so it's an honor to be here so i
understand here actually i think he's
got some of the best political instincts
in the world and perhaps in history
he's genuinely a wonderful human being
but once he started putting
uh separating women from their children
at the border and putting the children
in cages disavowing our intelligence
community
using uh racial slurs on his twitter
account it became impossible
it has very very little to do with me
being fired
and again for two years after my firing
i tried to stay loyal to him and his
agenda
uh but you can't stay loyalty in life is
symmetrical it's not asymmetrical
you can't stay loyal to lunacy and so uh
we'll be out there working to see him
uh go back to mar-a-lago and hopefully
we can calm
things down he made our country
unfortunately poorer weaker and sicker
uh and we need to heal that now and so i
i feel very
uh responsible and so i'm going to be in
there fighting uh until november third
do you think he's a lunatic well i know
he's a lunatic i don't have to think
that he's a lunatic just look at it
objectively
uh yeah of course he's a lunatic i mean
come on here's the problem what we do in
our society because he's in that
august office you know he's the
successor of eisenhower and roosevelt
and abraham lincoln
uh we have a tendency to attach normalcy
to somebody that is very abnormal and i
i understand that
i did that in the beginning i tried to
do that even after i got fired but no
you could look at this
objectively and say that the guy is a
full-blown lunatic
one topic given that uh the united
states is so
patriotic um comments that he allegedly
made
about soldiers killed in action being
suckers
and losers how damaging do you think
that could be for the president
i'm guessing he thinks it could be very
damaging which is why he's come out so
forcefully against those comments
well i think they're damaging and i
think everybody knows that those
comments are true
and i think it was very telling
yesterday jeff mason asked him
well why don't you have general kelly
release a statement uh he was with you
the whole time
give him permission to release a
statement obviously the general is not
going to speak
without the president's permission but
if uh
if you if you ask him to release the
statement he'll release a statement and
you know of course the president doesn't
want that so
i think that was very telling right
there so we all know that it's true
what happened how do you think that the
president might react if he loses
on the third of november will he take it
on the chin
i think he will i think ultimately what
you find with the bullies and cowards
like this you know he's a keyboard
warrior coward
i think he's going to get humiliated at
the polls and i think he'll he'll leave
if it's a super tight race
he may fake a head fake of that he's not
going to do that but he obviously will
do that
he's despised by the american military
it's not just the generals as he was
talking about yesterday
but it's deep into the ranks you can
just look at the polling there
the military's decidedly republican but
he's got
more than the majority of them against
him if you look at the polling so
he's got nowhere to go if you want to be
an autocrat and you want to hijack a
democracy
you better have a good relationship with
the military he's probably the most
hated commander-in-chief
in the modern era so he'll be leaving
uh if he loses and if he doesn't lose
you know god help us because
he's a very destructive very dangerous
guy he's called you it got personal he's
called you a nervous
neurotic wreck do you regret working for
him
the one that was really hurtful was he
called me an unstable nut job so i think
that that was the one that really got to
me gaby
was very upset about that that comment i
mean listen i mean that's his projection
anything that he's saying about a guy
like me or a guy like general mattis or
a guy like rex tillerson
is a projection frankly of how he feels
about himself and so
i don't mind when he calls me those
things i i wear those as a
badge of honor but if you notice i don't
really call him
those things i just look at it very
objectively and say that this is not a
person that
is fit to be the president of the united
states
and so let's move on and we should be
brave enough
to fear no man or woman for that matter
and speak our conscious about what's
going on in our society
and a quick thought about melania how
influential was she in the white house
well listen i like her very much my wife
and i like her
i don't like talking about their
relationship
i do think she is influential um and
she's a nice person and she's a good mom
and i wish
i wish melania well he went after my
wife on twitter i would never do that to
his wife
that's just shows you the type of low
life the guy actually is
uh i i do i wasn't aware of that what
tell do you want to tell me a little bit
more about what happened
no no it's fine i mean you could find it
on twitter my point is is that like i'm
not ted cruz
you know you're not going to go after my
family members without me putting up a
fight my
my point is though i would never do that
to melania trump or any of his family
members